[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
et au sénat
et cette semaine avec brigitte notre
invité roland lescure bonjour bonjour et
c'est brigitte qui vous présente bonjour
roland lescure sept députés la
république en marge des français établis
hors de france votre circonscription
comprend les états unis et le canada
vous êtes le président de la commission
des affaires économiques à l'assemblée
nationale
un job qui vous correspond assez bien
puisque vous étiez juste avant numéro 2
de l'un des plus gros fonds de pension
nord américain vous êtes le frère cadet
de pierre lescure pour les amoureux de
la télé et puis vous avez grandi à
montreuil-sous-bois entre un père
communiste et une mère syndicaliste à la
ratp
et pourtant et pourtant aujourd'hui vous
êtes macro nist c'est possible ce et en
même temps oui moi c'est pas le peu de
bleu pourtant je suis pas d'accord et
c'est grâce à tout ça se fume acronis
parce que ça fait partie évidemment ma
jeunesse de ma culture mon éducation et
ce qui m'a amené là où je suis le en
même temps c'est à la fois ne pas
oublier d'où on vient et c'est vrai que
j'ai eu une éducation une enfance très à
gauche très social très sensible aussi
aux valeurs républicaines et aux
quartiers des banlieues dans lequel j'ai
grandi merci m jusqu'aujourd'hui
oui oui oui et aussi est aussi une
carrière professionnelle qui a été
plutôt effectivement dans la finance
internationale même si je travaillais
pour une entreprise publique qui gérait
les retraites publiques des québécois et
donc je pense que je mets les deux en
cohérence dans mon action au quotidien
ne pas oublier d'où je viens et
notamment la composante sociale très
forte de ce qu'ont fait n'en déplaise à
certains mais aussi l'efficacité de
l'économie de l'entreprise qui n'est pas
une ennemie du social mais qui doit en
faire partie et on va voir votre regard
sur les actualités de cette semaine la
loi sur la sécurité globale qui vise à
protéger les policiers fait débat à
l'assemblée le gouvernement a proposé un
compromis sur l'article 24 qui interdit
la diffusion malveillantes d'image de
policiers en opérations de maintien de
l'ordre nouvelle accordé deux chambres
toutes quatrième budget rectificatif de
l'année il débloque 20 milliards d'euros
pour soutenir l'économie d'ici à la fin
de l'année pour faire face
or confinement
crise sanitaire l'exécutif prépare un
assouplissement du dispositif jean
castex a douché les espoirs d'un retour
à la normale cette semaine devant la
commission denquête corrida et on
commence par l'examen de la proposition
de loi controversée sur la sécurité
globale à l'assemblée la diffusion avec
une intention malveillante d'image de
policiers en opérations de maintien de
l'ordre le fameux article 24 cristallise
les mécontentements
certains ayant vu une atteinte aux
libertés fondamentales afin de trouver
un compromis le ministre de l'intérieur
a proposé un amendement garantissant la
liberté de la presse les précisions
d'elsa mondain gaza c'est l'article au
coeur de la controverse le numéro 24 de
la proposition de loi relative à la
sécurité globale voulue par le ministère
de l'intérieur
il prévoyait dans sa rédaction initiale
de punir d'un an d'emprisonnement et de
45000 euros d'amendé le fait de diffuser
par quelques moyen que ce soit et quel
qu'en soit le support
dans le but qu'il soit porté atteinte à
son intégrité physique ou psychique
l'image du visage ou tout autre élément
d'identification d'un agent de la police
nationale ou de la gendarmerie
nationales levée de boucliers chez les
journalistes
les associations de défense des libertés
publiques et les oppositions à gauche
tous craignent que cette mesure puisse
empêcher demain le travail de la presse
et la possibilité pour les manifestants
deux films et les forces de l'ordre en
cas de débordements notamment des doutes
sur cette disposition jusque dans la
majorité même certains au modem veulent
supprimer l'article
d'autres au sein du groupe la république
en marche préviennent qu'ils ne voteront
pas jeudi soir réunion de crise à
matignon autour du premier ministre jean
castex du ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin du patron du groupe la
république en marche christophe castaner
et celui du modem patrick mignola
l'objectif trouver un point
d'atterrissage et s'entendent sur une
nouvelle rédaction de l'article
vendredi l'amendement du gouvernement
est déposée il ajoute la mention sans
préjudice du droit d'informer et précise
que le but de porter atteinte à
l'intégrité physique ou psychique doit
être manifeste de quoi tenter
apaiser le débat mais l'épisode laissera
sûrement des traces entre la presse et
le gouvernement est entre la majorité et
le très présent ministre de l'intérieur
roland lescure gérald darmanin proposait
donc cet amendement à l'article 24 pour
garantir la liberté d'informer vous même
vous l'aviez proposé est ce que c'est un
amendement de compromis qui va mettre
finalement toute la majorité d'accord
j'espère bon d'abord très rapidement il
ya 23 articles avant le 24 et
quelques-uns après il faut pas les
oublier c'est une loi qui fait plein de
choses très bien sûr les polices
municipales sur la capacité à protéger
nos forces de l'homme mais aussi à
sécuriser nos concitoyens mais c'est
vrai que cet article faisait
controverses notamment parce que
certains notamment de vos confrères
s'inquiétait sur l'impact sur la liberté
d'informer moi j'ai grandi dans une
famille aussi de journalistes mon père
était journaliste à l'humanité et mon
frère vous l'avez dit était journaliste
donc je suis très sensible à ça ce que
j'ai dit c'est ce que moi j'ai étudié ça
très près l'article hôtel qu'il était
rédigé ne mettais en aucun cas en cause
la liberté de la presse
pourquoi pas une nouvelle ré déclare ya
ce qu'il n'y avait pas un vrai risque
tout de même si vous êtes obligé de le
rajouter dans une expression que j'aime
bien qu'ils aient ça va sans dire mais
peut-être que ça va mieux en le disant
donc ça allait s'en dire je pense que ça
ira mieux en le disant
la loi de 1881 finalement est suffisante
exactement mais je pense qu en le
précisant vous savez que les débats
parlementaires la manière dont les
amendements et les articles sont rédigés
et tout ce qui est dit dans le cas du
débat permet d'éclairer les juges qui
ensuite sera amené à prendre des
décisions
donc le fait qu'on est explicitement
mentionné ça je pense sera évidemment
intégré dans des raids dans des
procédures judiciaires que j'espère le
moins nombreuses possibles mais qui
pourrait venir pour appliquer cette loi
évidemment tous les débats qu'on a eu
autour aussi vont éclairer les juges
donc c'est très bien on a eu ce débat en
grande partie d'ailleurs grâce à vos
confrères mais aussi grâce à certains
des miens et c'est très bien ça permet
d'ailleurs été du coup est derrière vous
on sait que le modem notamment s'y était
opposé et demander la suppression de cet
article 24 avaient réussi à les rallier
d'abord c'est une partie du modem
instincts des pois un amendement déposé
au nom d'une
avec un certain nombre d'entre eux kinky
nantes qui n'en étaient pas signataire
je pense qu'effectivement cet amendement
permet de resserrer les rangs sur tout
clarifier les choses
terrifiés l'intention du législateur
faut quand même pas oublier qu'il ya
trois jours il y avait devant la même
assemblée nationale une manifestation
extrêmement violente avec des policiers
qui se sont trouvés acculés dans une
entrée d'immeuble et caillassés ces
gens-là kikai installé policiers ils
n'étaient pas là pour la liberté de la
presse
ils étaient là pour casser du flic il
faut pas oublier que ça aussi c'est un
problème aujourd'hui la violence
vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre doit
être jugulée et cette proposition de loi
vise aussi à protéger mardi ces jus des
journalistes qui ont été arrêtés pour
avoir filmé la manifestation dont qui
était en train là de faire leur travail
et les policiers avec cette loi on
vraiment eu l'impression qu'ils
pouvaient en avoir une interprétation
très restrictive qui pouvait les arrêter
alors même qu'ils ne faisaient que leur
travail a list de france télévisions
d'ailleurs qu'est des photographes des
journalistes et je pense qu'il faudra
faire toute la lumière sur ce qui s'est
passé vraiment mais en tout cas oui il
fallait préciser le fait que les
journalistes à pouvoir faire leur
travail en toute liberté
moi j'y suis extrêmement sensible et je
suis sûr que le ministre de l'intérieur
aussi d'ailleurs donc aux îles
photographes des réalisateurs qui n'ont
pas toujours de carte de presse eux
aussi auront leur liberté finalement
d'informer comme tout citoyen mais
d'abord n'importe qui aujourd'hui et
demain peut filmer un policier peut
filmer aussi un manifestant train de
casser un policier est peu le diffuser
c'était vrai avant la loi
ce sa vraie après ce qui ne sera plus
possible après la loi c'est de diffuser
ces images en menaçant les gens qui sont
dessus et en incitant à la haine vis à
vis de ces gens là franchement c'est du
bon sens donc je comprends qu'ils aient
eu un peu d'incompréhension autour de
paroles qui ont lieu autour de cette loi
mais cet article quand on lit en plus à
mende et comme il a été amendée il ne
souffre aucune ambiguïté le problème il
venait finalement de cet article 24 ou
c'est gérald darmanin qui a crispé les
choses non je pense que le problème ils
venaient de tout ce qui a été dit autour
de la loi est ce que je découvre depuis
trois ans et que c'est pas la première
fois il était en parlant du du floutage
lorsque gérald darmanin a évoqué la
question du foot us qu'il n'avait pas
tout de suite
nami le ver dans le fruit et poser
problème dans un an
en tout cas je pense que tout le monde
sait puisque si vous faites une
recherche sur le texte de loi
terme de floutage n'y est pas en
évoquant ce terme-là il n'a pas évoqué
les comptes plus directe de la loi ainsi
que les journalistes avant de revenir
sur ses propos que j'en aie se devaient
se manifester auprès de la préfecture de
police dans une manifestation
et il est revenu sur ses propos donc là
de ce point de vue là je pense que la
polémique et qui a mis un temps
messieurs vous nommez moi j'ai vu aussi
énormément de prise de parole d'un
certain nombre de gens dans l'opposition
qui visiblement n'avait pas lu le texte
de loi alors qu'avant de le voter
la moindre des choses c'est de le faire
et de vos confrères qui s'inquiétait de
manière peut être légitime
mais là encore je pense pas tout à fait
en phase avec le texte tel qu'il était
écrit donc on est ici devant deux
chaînes parlementaires où la rigueur je
pense est de mise quand on lit cet
article de loi
a fortiori comme il est rédigé
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune ambiguïté la
liberté d'informer et totalement
préservée et on protège ce qui nous
protège
il ya aussi l'article 25 et qui pose
problème là c'est sur les sanctions
avec donc un texte de loi sur le
séparatisme qui dans un cas prévoit
75000 euros alors que votre texte la
prévoit 45000 euros en cas de diffusion
d'image value malveillance lequel vous
allez conserver finalement d'abord je
pense qu'effectivement les deux articles
tels qu'issus de seine qui coexistent
aujourd'hui devront sans doute converger
et ça c'est les examens des navettes
parlementaires donc au sénat et à
l'assemblée qui permettront de les faire
converger
ça fait quand même un peu doublon non
c'est pas très incohérent alors ne
dispose pas tout à fait la même chose
ils sont pas tout à fait sur le même
champ l'article 25 c pour l'ensemble des
agents publics pour laquelle on renforce
les amendes mais qui sont aussi prévus
pour tout à chacun c'est à dire que vous
savez bien que suite à l'attentât
horrible qui a coûté la vie à samuel
pâtit on a décidé de mettre dans la loi
des sanctions très fort pour ceux qui
déclenchent des chasse en meute sur
internet et a fortiori quand elles sont
destinées à chasser en meute des agents
publics des enseignants des policiers
est par ailleurs dans le cas de la
proposition de la sécurité sur les
dettes des menaces très particulière sur
les agents de la force de l'ordre
il ya cet article 24
il faut qu'ils convergent tous les deux
je suis sûr qu'on va le faire dans le
cadre de l'examen des deux projets le
doigt on va être patient et les deux
chambres vont faire leur travail juste
une dernière question avec ce texte avec
la future loi sur le séparatisme avec la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence est ce
que l'exécutif est en train de céder à
une dérive liberticide
non non on est dans une crise économique
une crise sanitaire
une crise sociale il ya aussi des
attentats terroristes
on l'a vue qui malheureusement ce risque
n'a pas disparu ont lieu donc il faut
qu'on arrive à protéger les françaises
et les français protéger ce qui nous
protège et avec un sujet pas simple mais
je voudrais insister une seconde là
dessus on est aujourd'hui face à une
partie de la population et les minimes
mais qui n'a plus de respect pour les
forces de l'ordre et cette partie minime
qui caillassent les policiers est en
train de laisser à penser que du coup
nos forces de l'ordre ne sont pas au
rendez vous de la démocratie donc un
espèce de cercle vicieux qui se met en
place contre lequel il faut lutter il
faut que nos forces de l'ordre soit
irréprochable est à l'étude et qui
disent comme tout ce que dit m
finalement on n'a pas voté emmanuel
macron pourra voir l'état d'urgence le
séparatisme et la loi c'est que l'avocat
jean pierre mignard qui vous savez qu'on
sable de la partie justice lors de la
campagne qui dit bien qu'il est déçu et
que c'était pas du tout pour ça qu'il
avait fait quand pas moi j'ai pas voté
manuel mâcon pour faire face à un virus
pour faire face à des attentats
terroristes et pour faire face
vous l'avez dit j'ai grandi dans une
famille où on manifestait beaucoup moi
quand j'étais gamin j'allais avec mes
parents dans les manifestations il
m'emmenait sans problème le dimanche
sans aucune crainte que je sois moi-même
tabassé par des manifestants le jour de
la marche pour le climat il y avait
trois cent mille personnes à montréal il
y en avait dix mille à paris c'est pas
parce que les parisiens et - climat
clément mal c'est que les gens ont
aujourd'hui peur de manifester parce que
dans ces manifestations il ya des
groupuscules qui sont là pour tabasser
et absolument pas pour manifester donc
c'est ce cercle vicieux qu'il faut
arrêter la police doit faire sa part du
travail pour essayer d'apaiser au
maximum ces manifestations mais faut pas
oublier que ces heurts y viennent de
gens qui sont là pour mettre à sac
paris est pas manifester pacifiquement
allez on poursuit cette émission avec le
compromis trouvé entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat sur le quatrième
budget rectificatif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce texte prévoit 20 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour faire face aux
dépenses de la deuxième vague de
l'épidémie de covile et pour faire face
au confinement l'accent est mis sur les
aides aux pme et aux indépendants
contraints à la fia fameux tueur
pierre-henri holderbaum face à la
dégradation de l'économie le
gouvernement assume et sort le carnet de
chèques 20 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour ce quatrième projet
de loi de finances rectificative
nous avons fait le choix mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs d'accepter la
dégradation des finances publiques pour
répondre à la crise et les chiffres que
je vous présente avec ce plfr 4 en sont
l'illustration en détail ce texte
prévoit d'aider les entreprises et les
commerces les plus touchées 10,9
milliards d'euros pour le fonds de
solidarité 3,2 milliards d'euros pour le
chômage partiel et 3 milliards pour les
exonérations de cotisations sociales
pour les entreprises
autre point pour aider les plus
précaires le budget rectificatif prévoit
1,1 milliard d'euros pour les personnes
touchant le rsa et les étudiants
boursiers pour la gauche le compte n'y
est pas le secours catholique estime que
la barre des 10 millions de pauvres en
france sera dépassée cette année toutes
les associations et les syndicats vous
demande d'agir davantage
entendez les au contraire le budget
rectificatif est largement approuvée par
la droite
ce texte aujourd'hui nous traitons la
fin de gestion pour l'année 2020 et les
mesures d'urgence indispensable pour se
tenir notre économie et nos concitoyens
la majorité sénatoriale a eu gain de
cause sur le rétablissement des 4,7
millions d'euros pour le milieu sportif
dans les apports du sénat conserver 8
millions d'euros prévus pour la filière
équine ainsi qu'un soutien pour les
transports publics
en revanche la taxe sur les ventes en
ligne n'a pas été retenue par le
gouvernement
un sujet que la majorité de la chambre
haute va remettre sur la table pour le
budget de 2021
oui le texte devrait être définitivement
adopté le 24 9 en novembre l'a entendue
dans le sujet roland lescure le sénat a
adopté à plusieurs reprises d amendement
pour taxer et les gaffes à dans le
contexte de cette crise dont ils sortent
souvent grand gagnant est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce principe
d'abord la taxation negafa nous l'avons
voté oui la passion ce que le sénat
voulait voter
la taxation des ventes en ligne et on
aime bien quand on traverse des périodes
un peu difficile mouvementée en france
choisir un grand méchant donc le grand
méchant de la semaine ou d'amazon c'est
amazon vous défendez amazon non je
souhaite qu'on ne montre pas du doigt un
acteur économique qui représente que 20%
des ventes en ligne cdiscount fnac mais
aussi plein de petites entreprises qui
se développent qu'on reconnaisse que
notre vrai sujet c'est que nos petits
commerces sont insuffisamment développée
sur internet et qu'il faut les aider à
se développer et on a voté des budgets
pour ça et que par ailleurs le vrai
sujet d' amazon c'est pas un grand
méchant qui fait tomber le commerce en
france
c'est un un des acteurs du commerce en
ligne qui permet d'ailleurs
paradoxalement de développer le commerce
en ligne parce que des petits commerces
héberge deux plateformes sur amazon mais
qui ne payent pas les impôts qu'ils
devraient payer
c'est ça le vrai sujet aujourd'hui vous
avez des petits commerces qui paye
d'impôts et un grand commerce seulement
qu'on puisse dire c'est que ce
exceptionnel sur amazon ça pourrait pas
mettre aussi la beauté et on l'a voté
aussi sur google sur facebook c'est ça
qu'il faut faire il faut surtout le
faire au niveau européen et on est en
train de convaincre l'europe avec ses
dans le programme d'ursula von der leyen
de voter ce genre de choses au niveau
européen là on voit bien qu amazon vous
tend la main et accepte de décaler le
black friday d'une semaine donc au
vendredi 4 décembre
est-ce que là il ya un élément de
négociation justement pour éviter d'être
trop taxés à l'avenir est ce que c'est
une façon de renouer appelé non moi je
pense que amazon fait surtout de la
communication il a fait bien j'avais
dire tant mieux
bruno le maire a très bien joué le coup
après que il a en fait indiqué qu' on ne
pourrait ré ouvrir les commerces qu'à
deux conditions 1 évidemment c'est
l'essentiel que la situation sanitaire
s'améliore et que si elle s'améliore il
faut pas qu'on ait dès le vendredi ou le
samedi un black friday ou un black
saturday qui fait qu'on en veut on
on envahit tous les commerces et on se
retrouve avec une situation sanitaire
dégradé donc en gros il leur a dit si
vous voulez qu'on envisage d'ouvrir il
va falloir décalé le black friday sinon
c'est pas possible
amazon avait besoin de redorer son
blason de critiquer un petit peu donc
bravo à bruno le maire d'avoir utilisé
ça comme un bras de fer il y avait un
certain nombre de gens qui votaient des
taxes inapplicable d'autres qui disent
ah il faut interdire le black friday ce
qui est impossible également on a un
ministre des finances qui a fait un bras
de fer utile et qui a convaincu à la
fois amazon mais aussi des grandes
surfaces de repousser le black friday de
manière à ce qu'on puisse
raisonnablement tranquillement réouvrir
le commerce le plus tôt possible
franchement chapeau là on parle
évidemment de la consommation mais on
voit aussi que et bien cette ce
confinement cette crise est la creuse et
beaucoup les inégalités et à près de 10
millions de pauvres nous dit le secours
catholique à la fin de l'année est-ce
que ce budget rectificatif est ce que le
prochain budget il prévoit assez pour
les plus vulnérables pour pour savoir
moi en tout cas il prévoit beaucoup
m'ont d'abord il faut pas oublier que la
meilleure manière de sortir les gens de
la provôté ou d'éviter qu'ils y tombe
c'est de les garder à l'emploi il faut
surtout pas opposer les entreprises des
dépôts non mais là on a 9 % de chômage
donc on a déjà des gens qui sont sans
emploi
oui et on avait il faut le noter quand
même avant la crise une pauvreté qui
commençait à décliner pourquoi parce
qu'on a remis les gens au travail
donc faut surtout pas oublier cette
partie de l'équation cela dit vous avez
raison il ya des gens qui sont
particulièrement affectées par les 9%
vous mentionnez mais quand même
plusieurs millions de françaises et de
français qui aujourd'hui souffrent
particulièrement de cette crise il faut
les aider
on l'a fait déjà peut-être pas assez on
verra mais on l'a quand même fait pas
mal avec les 150 euros d'apl les 150
euros pour les bénéficiaires du rsa avec
en plus des sommes pour les enfants le
repas un euro pour les universitaires
pour les étudiants donc on a fait un
certain nombre de choses il faut qu'on
suive ça il faut aussi qu'on aide les
associations qui font un travail
exceptionnel
malheureusement on a une crise
économique historique donc oui la
pauvreté augmente
j'allais dire c'est malheureusement
normal est-ce qu'on a aussi kick pardon
il profite de cette crise car certains
ont pris goût au chômage partiel 1 selon
la ministre du travail isabelle borne on
évalue qui aurait déjà une fraude de 200
millions d'euros
selon le parisien sur une dépense au
total de 30 milliards mécanismes il faut
aujourd'hui pour contrôler ces
entreprises ce qui faute
ben c'est ce qui avait été dit à
l'époque on avait dit on au qu'on ne
contrôle pas a priori normal ou
contrôler a priori évidemment en pleine
crise sanitaire vous n'allez pas dire
venez me prouver vous avez besoin les
chômage partiel pour le faire signer il
faut peut-être aller on a été très
efficace au printemps parce qu'il
fallait garder ce lien d'emploi
maintenant il faut pouvoir contrôler et
espérer pouvoir récupérer l'argent non
par les 30 milliards et 30 mineurs ils
étaient bien venus ils ont permis de
maintenir ce lien d'emploi il faut être
je dirais acea tolérant sur les fraudes
qui a eu mais on est vraiment dans la
marche quand même la plupart mais des
entrepreneurs avec lesquels je parle et
je travaille régulièrement et la plupart
des salariés
ils veulent travailler et n'ont pas pu
le faire et ça faut le comprendre mal
que des grands groupes de distributeurs
comme carrefour y est aujourd'hui
recours oui on leur a fermé à moi qui
adore réunion du non essentiels ne sont
pas là ben voilà on en fait m non c'est
bien les dividendes aux actionnaires le
fait que ces groupes heidi c'est pas mal
enrichis pendant la crise et enrichit je
suis patient verra les résultats à la
fin de l'année je pense pas que ce soit
des grands gagnants de la crise ils ont
évidemment un peu moins perdu d'autres
parce qu'ils sont restés ouverts qu'ils
ont pu vendre des produits et merci
grâce à eux on a pu se nourrir comme les
commerces alimentaires d'ailleurs qui ne
sont pas des grandes surfaces dont faut
pas oublier l'essentiel
c'est vrai que pour répondre à la colère
légitime des petits commerces
on a fermé la moitié des supermarchés et
que du coup ils ont même dû y mettre des
gens au chômage partiel c'est c'est
comme ça et donc il n'y a pas de raison
de dire ah bah vous pour vous le chômage
partiel là vous n'avez pas de mât aile
et on termine avec le plus de la semaine
le déconfinement enfin on va voir si le
terme est réellement adaptée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que le chef de l'état va
s'exprimer la semaine prochaine sur la
crise sanitaire le premier ministre a
mis en garde contre un déconfinement
trop rapide il s'agira plutôt d'un
assouplissement du dispositif existant
écoutez je n'imagine pas qu'on saura le
1er décembre comme on l'était avec les
mêmes règles applicables dans l'entrée
du deuxième confinement je pense que
nous en ferons une sortie progressive si
on peut desserrer effectivement les
commerces de proximité qui ne sont pas
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui fermées parce
qu'il ne sommes pas ils ne vendent pas
des des produits alimentaires ou autres
ce pourrait être effectivement les
premiers concernés on l'a déjà dit les
petits commerces pourraient être les
premiers concernés c'est ce qu'a dit
jean castex devant la commission cette
semaine commission denquête qu'ovide
quand vont-ils rouvrir ces petits
commerces
le plus tôt possible je veux pas faire
le normand mais évidemment tout dépend
de la condition sanitaire pour l'instant
les cours prennent une bonne direction
les contaminations baisse d
hospitalisation d animation fait un
plateau et ont même baissé un peu ton
faut que ça continue
si ça continue dans les jours qui
viennent on pourra ouvrir et on ouvrira
dès que possible car c'est la date du
samedi 28 novembre
voilà si c'est possible ou savait que le
président va se prononcer mercredi donc
la décision sera prise mercredi 9 a dit
le président obama s'exprimera à priori
c'est mercredi que prévu et puis ensuite
on aura sans doute le premier ministre
et les ministres qui nous donneront les
détails mais on peut espérer d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible mais on sait bien que
personne aujourd'hui ne souhaite garder
les commerces fermés si on le fait c'est
pour des raisons sanitaires qui sont
impérieuse si celle-là s'améliore on
ouvrira mais avec discipline c'est
justement avec quel protocole scène
c'est pas c'est pas les grandes eaux où
on ouvre tout et tout va bien on va
rester extrêmement contraint extrêmement
discipliné on sait bien que le
déconfinement il a eu du bon on a bien
géré les écoles on a bien géré la
reprise de l'économie mais on s'est sans
doute un peu trop relâché cet été c'est
ce que disaient aussi
texte déconfinement il est à bout moi je
pense qu'on va en trouver un autre je
sais pas encore lequel je fais confiance
au président en général ils nous en
trouve avec brio mais mais c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas dans du confit né dans une
ferme on sera pas des confiné dans une
semaine on serait encore contraint il va
falloir encore être extrêmement
discipliné extrêmement rigoureux avec
intérêt peut-être peut-être mais en tout
cas il va falloir être extrêmement
rigoureux se sera pas le nord- est
l'habituel ce sera certainement de pâles
le réveillon de la saint sylvestre
festifs comme on aime à la voir mais on
va se déplacer quand même un peu pour
noël j'espère j'espère qu'on pourra se
déplacer mais sans doute un peu est ce
que les règles qui ont été édictées
quand même avec les commerces
essentiellement essentielle elle n'était
pas un petit peu absurde il ya eu à bien
cet article du quotidien 22e journal de
centre gauche die zeit qui a qualifié la
france d' absurde distants qu'est ce que
vous en pensez avec un petit peu de
recul aujourd'hui
vous savez on est le seul pays au monde
qu à l'attestation téléchargeable sur
nos antiques au vide pour pouvoir sortir
promener son chien et faire des courses
donc c'est vrai que vu de l'étranger ça
peut apparaître comme si on n'avait pas
eu qu'est-ce qui serait passée
connaissons les français tels qu'on les
connaît tels qu'on les aime nos bigeard
des règles absurdes pour les français on
est obligé d'avoir des règles un peu
plus qu'ailleurs je connais un certain
dans nos pays notamment aux prédateurs
d'indiscipliné les français en tout cas
aime bien qu'on leur dise exactement là
où ils peuvent marcher
quitte d'ailleurs à ce qu'ils puissent
marcher un peu sur la marge pour jouer
un peu avec la règle et c'est vrai que
quand les instructions sont pas claires
en france on a tendance à râler quand
elles sont là on a parfois aussi
tendance à peu à râler parce qu'elles
sont là mais malgré tout il faut
reconnaître quand même que si les
indicateurs sanitaires continuent à
s'améliorer ce confinement aura été un
succès quand même avoir des règles ce
sont les restaurateurs et ceux qui
tiennent des bars est-ce que vous pouvez
leur donner des perspectives mais
forcément malheureusement les
perspectives sont assez sombres puisque
vous savez que c'est le lieu où on se
contaminent de plus pourquoi pas la
faute des restaurateurs c'est parce
qu'on enlève son masque on est sur des
tables à ses proches même si on a réussi
à les éloigner un peu
donc il va falloir attendre c'est sûr
ils ont besoin de perspectives on va
essayer de leur donner mais il me semble
totalement impossible qu'on puisse
ouvrir les restaurants autour des fêtes
de noël
il faut pouvoir se mettre en condition
de les ouvrir après je ne sais pas quand
mais là encore après avec quel protocole
vous le dis exactement comme on sait
bien que les terrasses en hiver c'est
plus compliqué et donc
c'était une manière peut-être d'ouvrir
les restaurants qu aurait permis de
limiter un peu les dégâts donc ça va pas
être facile on travaille moi je parle à
des restaurateurs régulièrement
eux aussi sont en train de se réinventer
ils font des livraisons à domicile
il fonde et click and collect le fameux
mais beaucoup vont faire faillite mais
j'espère que non sire que à des enjeux
je pense qu'on verra cette semaine c'est
d'adapter là encore une fois encore les
règles de soutien à ces nouvelles règles
disciplinaires donc si on dure pour les
restaurateurs faudra sans doute revoir
le fonds de solidarité qui permet de les
aider merci roland lescure merci dalle
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
c'est la fin de parlement et dont on se
retrouve bien évidemment la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]